Welcome to the Super Family's fifth movie, Escape from Mata Nui.
Now here is Amanda Young to give you an important message about the members of the Super Family.
I'm sorry to disappoint you, Basil fans, because Basil has left the Super Family and is not coming back, but Kopika is joining.
She is a ice...she's an...well, she's an ice villager. I forget what they're called.
Here's Adam Young.
We now take you to Mata Nui to tell you of the first part of our movie.
...tree trunk before.
Hey Bella, what are you cooking this morning?
Apple pie.
Have you ever noticed the Bohrok...I mean the Toa never came back from their adventure?
They just straight got captured.
Well, you never know. Maybe they might have got lost.
Maybe.
They could have never got off the island, because I don't know.
Because the fuel was pretty low when they left.
Possible.
Yeah.
Boar better? I mean, um, not boar, I mean ice better.
Um, put it down in there. It's gonna wake everybody up.
Yeah.
Welding swords.
Vacuuming.
Yeah.
Costume.
Baby costumes and baby tests whom you just found.
Why don't you go check and see if the doctor's in yours okay?
Okay.
You wanna go up to the spy tower?
Get me some snacks.
Yeah.
Get me a cup.
You better not. I'm gonna call the Toa.
Hello?
Send the Bohrok.
I'm gonna go get them.
Control the hole. Be there as soon as possible.
Landed there safely?
I hope so.
Oh, nice.
Let's call it.
Hello?
We wouldn't have to do it ourselves.
I hope this doesn't have to do with anything.
Super family, I bring you here today to tell you that we will face an ultimate evil.
I think we will face an ultimate evil because I have sent the Bohrok and Toa on a mission to stop the Bohrok, but the Toa have not come back.
So I sent the Bohrok.
I could not make contact with both of them, so we're going to have to go ourselves.
Your bravery will help us get through.
All of your power will add up.
Instead of firing a final beam at our enemy, whoever it is, instead of firing a final beam, you will be firing your most powerful attack as a final beam.
We will go there and show them that they...
...are not the most powerful.
Once we go there, we'll destroy that evil.
And together, we will prevail.
Let's go.
There's his lair.
We'll be there soon.
Everybody ready?
Yeah.
Whoa!
If there's a basket, avoid it.
Spirits of Makuta, we will destroy you once again.
No, you will not.
Oh, yes, we will.
We are much more powerful than you.
Makuta.
And instead of using that final beam, we're going to be using our most powerful attacks as a final beam.
I have trained much more.
And I have a very powerful weapon.
You probably don't know what it is.
I don't.
Yes, you don't.
What?
How many times before?
Oh, is that so?
I did something else?
Something like this?
The other one didn't fire her most powerful attack.
Uh-huh.
Now she's a big bomb.
But what about the other one?
She's a big power.
I'm going to have to go to my next part.
Now you're going to have to battle my most obedient form.
Yeah.
Get ready to challenge me.
Martin, Theresa, battle them.
Makuta, did you know something?
No, I didn't.
Whatever you're talking about, I don't know what it is.
I mean, I do know what it is.
Ha, ha, ha.
Did you know that in a family of four, yes, Lapsha failed.
It's Damansaur.
Yes.
Get Makuta.
What does that egg taste like?
It tastes sort of like, I don't know, because I got the super climate attack.
New Erahma.
Baby Jess, get her.
Fusion.
Weeow.
I'm putting on a block screen.
Sir, I'm putting on a block screen.
Yes.
Block screen is on.
on now she can't see it attack her you can't attack me you can't attack me you can't attack me
you can't attack me
now my most powerful attack you said that the last battle
fighter hyper beam is he knocked out i blocked it again defeated that idiot
you don't stand a chance you only know so crash was taking care of her it's like you know the
whole thing makuta i think you're so cool i was talking about i'll get it oh no you don't
now she won't hear my ear hey did you hear his nose ring thanks dude i did that let's use it
okay arm's going back on i'm getting you're getting bored makuta
you're getting bored makuta you're getting bored makuta
you're getting bored makuta because you aren't even attacking at least i got this
because you aren't even attacking at least i got this
because you aren't even attacking at least i got this chrono what is it for it's the
chrono what is it for it's the
chrono what is it for it's the chrona of um whatever it is
chrona of um whatever it is
chrona of um whatever it is i hey this is makuta i command you to
i hey this is makuta i command you to
i hey this is makuta i command you to take off your chrono shielding that's
take off your chrono shielding that's cheating you mean
cheating you mean
cheating you mean ron may have failed but my new drama
ron may have failed but my new drama
ron may have failed but my new drama there's nothing you can do to stop my
new drama hey come on we get our first enemy nightmares only i believe i have had enough of
this going for the chrono get here it's grandma pikachu i mean pikachu and get ready grandma
pikachu we're gonna go oh you're my cuda it's sheila and agent nine my blaster this time
attack the rod doing sheila kick harder than that but i'm stronger than you still that always hits
go blaine shut up is he becoming more shit he's climbing all over us
we're in the sky good use the hyper she the hyper flashes
use a hyper attack on her knock her out talking so soft
why didn't you fire your most powerful attack
do i have to
battle now
good thing she can't take off my mask
she talks like an idiot
mask back on
darn it you can't
attack nui ram nui jaga
have a taste of her
but no
talk so quiet
get sarika
use the crystal beam
it is much more powerful this time
which one is the real one
turn it off
now use super confusion
now that's got her really well
confusion to knock her out
why ain't you going to fire her most powerful attack
don't i shouldn't have said that
i think i can get out
yeah we have the same feeling
out by some sort of force
what tanuk
fire their most powerful attacks into the sky
oh
oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh look at that
To the defeat the super family except for dr. Senor and Stacey and first when you're yeah
I wonder if the surgery on my neck did ain't good to my power and all that
It probably did
Thanks, bro. I'm gonna battle now the tallest and the shortest are about to battle you think you're so powerful
And that's the last time I'll fix it for you
No, that's all that going to meditate. I mean we are going to meditate
You won't be able to use confusion on me. I'm knocked out too for some reason. Let's put yours on bar, too
You haven't even earned your canoe eka comma yet
But I've earned your but I've earned the canoe eka Kari darn. I'm behind you
Well, actually you have more than fast than me going to take a break who is getting his head back to a pro hot, too
Hey, I was taking a break
Not anymore
You'll start the talk. I knew is coming back. I'll go hot so you can keep taking your rest
Shut up ask of shielding, but you're not going to take a break now and break so I'm going to have to battle
Tohunga
They got something perfect I love use this one more time very nice flip that's because yours are fake you Eramu
Get to the tower
We're going to have to battle
I told the toa
Who cares long as we get to battle this time. Yes, what Makuta?
What I sound evil
Sorry, but pocket don't do that again. It's like all boring now, but my mask back on hey
well
Makuta will be scared of this attack
Huh, it's me a ton more powerful Makuta
Copaca keep battling
You can't attack me
I have a shield on or somebody to get in it. I
am ready to bet I
Am ready to battle spirit of Makuta
Sure affecting him
dead
Xolaywa all right all the dragon and all the tohunga go all at the same time
Chance with my mask I get I better make it off me
Oh, it's an invisible crab. Is that your new most powerful one of your most powerful. It's no, I ain't you gonna try the XO tell
Oh
You don't need effective man. We will battle and see who will win good or evil
You may have won this evil last time, but you won't actually
I'm dying not to die know what we need
Hmm, you think you're so cool?
XO galley
But there is less gravity I have heated the ground
Her mask I
Will tempt you galley you will come to the evil side
Destroy galley is defeated water blast Stacy battle her
Use the hyper beam right good thing you chewed her hand up
She better not use some of her powers oh no
She has the power to control weather attack her
What is it
Yes, that's it keep her from firing our most powerful attack battle her use the hyper beam
Okay, Dad.
Now you finally get to feel...
Better not do that head bash thing.
That's what you get for chewing on my daughter's hand.
Let's attack her.
Mwaka and Conra have fainted.
Now you don't.
It's going to taste delicious.
You can knock her out.
You're way too powerful.
You try, too.
Okay.
I'll take the top row.
She is knocked out.
Yes.
I hope she doesn't fire her most powerful attack.
Knocked out yet.
I hope so.
Yes, it is me.
Makuta, I have a speech.
May not destroy evil.
We will destroy you, Makuta.
You.
We will battle to see who will actually win this...
This struggle between good and evil.
Though there are many more evils before...
After you that will be more powerful than you.
Hey!
There will be.
There's one reason why we live forever.
To protect the universe at all times.
Get ready.
Battle, Makuta.
Spirit.
Let's battle.
Sure.
For the final time.
I will take them out one at a time.
Now.
We will battle, new Jaga.
Makuta.
Caravan.
I'd love to see you try.
Oh, sorry.
I'm ready.
The only one's left over.
At the same time.
You'll never understand.
Good's power.
Because.
You don't have that power.
Come on, Mwaka.
What do you got?
You have trained, Mwaka.
Yes, I have.
Well, watch this.
There's your pile of...
Klandess are destroying me.
I will not use that attack on you.
The time has come.
You must battle with me.
But.
Before I...
But before I battle you...
And while...
While I'm meditating.
You must see what you have done to your sons.
I have used one of my most powerful attacks on them.
And since you pushed them forward, like the last time.
You are responsible for destroying them.
First off.
Mwaka.
Your best son.
Muramu.
Nui-Jaga.
Nui-Ragu.
Nui-Rama.
And.
Con-Ra.
Now.
We must battle, Makuta.
You are a weakling.
And there is no excuse for that.
Makuta, we will battle now.
Why does your computer always do that, Makuta?
I do not know.
Has joined with the Powerball.
Now I will use this Powerball to charge with my most powerful attack.
And destroy...
I will block it.
Now we will battle.
Super Family has defeated me for the last time.
Get away, you freaking stooge.
It's a really...
Wee-Baa.
We hope you enjoyed Super Family's fifth movie, Escape from Mata Nui.
Now join us on the sixth movie, Return Home.
Which is the Christmas one, of course.
There will be no battle for the Christmas one.
That's a show.
See you on the next video.
Okay, I turned the camera off.
Okay.
Was that perfect?
Yeah, it was.
Let's build them back together first.
Okay, that's nice.
You build them back together.
Leave them to the others.
Why?
Matthias, there's bad news.
What's happened?
It's old Methuselah.
Is he...
No, he's alive.
But he's badly hurt.
Matthias, I have words to speak with you.
It was Chickenhound, wasn't it?
Him and Sela.
Probably.
But that doesn't matter right now.
Yes, it does.
I know you're hurting, Matthias.
But you can't let your pain blind you.
Cornflower's right.
Well, what am I supposed to do?
Ask yourself the important question.
Who's really behind this?
Clooney?
Yes.
Where is Clooney?
Master Matthias, them words is what I've been trying to speak in.
I think I know where him is.
What?
Feel him?
Someone down below be digging.
Father Abbott, could you please get everyone together, quickly?
Of course, my son.
What are we having for breakfast?
Matthias, this really isn't the time to be thinking of food.
Cornflower.
All right.
Um...
Porridge.
Hot porridge?
Oh, Clare!
They've defeated me with...
Well done, everyone.
And with porridge yet?
Well done.
How is Methuselah?
Only time will tell.
And what about this traitor?
Oh, dear.
Yes, I suppose there must be some form of punishment, mustn't there?
Bury her up to her neck in red ants, then hang the wretch from the tower before you draw and quarter her?
Or we could let her go.
Are you crazy?
Not really.
But Clooney is.
I'm sure he will know how to deal with her.
Now, wait a minute.
There's no need for that.
I'm sure we can come to a better arrangement.
I can be of great service.
I'm a healer, after all.
I'm a healer!
If I were you, I'd run.
Pious!
They'll never find me now.
I made it!
Hello?
Is somebody there?
Asmodeus.
I will show you eternity.
Discover the interactive world of the Redwall television series at www.redwalltv.com.
Featuring interactive games, stunning visuals, and fascinating educational content.
Visit redwalltv.com.
What a coat of arms is.
Well, you know the way we have a signature.
Well, a coat of arms was a man's signature or his family's signature.
But your coat of arms would apply to where you came from.
You see, not a million miles from where we're sitting now, there's a city called Chester.
And they have three little beehives.
Because that meant industry and work.
So if the people were hard workers, they had beehives.
If they were warriors, they'd have a sword.
You see, and that would stand for truth and justice and defending.
So you made up your family crest.
That's what they used to call it, a family crest.
Of the things that meant a lot to you.
It's nice to have something to identify yourself by, isn't it?
Look at that!
A crest!
Let's see, he's got...
Is that a deer?
A knight's head?
A shield?
And these are called lozenges.
Lozenges and sort of stripes there.
Who knows, it may have been a portcullis, you know, on them gates.
Security, yeah?
This is the resting place of Moorcroft Kirk of Liverpool.
Who was buried here in...
1750...
Is that a five?
1755.
Moorcroft's been there a long time.
But he left his mark.
He left his crest.
Blood!
Get your crew organized or I'll have your skulls for skittles!
He's a pretty good, scary, mean character.
He's actually worse than Cruella did.
He's a bit of a villain in the Dalmatian movie.
The way he cracks his tail and stuff,
and the way he's really rough with the other...
with his army.
The high, warm sun shone down on Clooney the Scourge.
Clooney was coming!
He was big and tough, an evil rat with ragged fur and curved, jagged teeth.
Truly enormous.
Whip-like tail!
But you don't have a title.
Clooney the Scourge!
The hall of the ferret gate!
The weasel bell!
The drowning!
For this is now Clooney's castle!
You see, who is Clooney?
Clooney is a bully.
Clooney is a warlord.
A conqueror.
Clooney the Great.
Clooney the Savage.
Clooney the Scourge.
And behind it all, he's a coward.
He's gotta be backed up by this huge army.
They've gotta follow him everywhere.
He gives the orders.
He looks the path.
But, behind it all, Clooney knows
that in the end, good will defeat evil.
What does Matthias want more than anything?
A. A million dollars.
B. The keys to the kingdom.
C. To marry Constance.
Or D. To be a great mouse warrior.
And the answer is...
D. To be a great mouse warrior.